the leader of Isis has been killed
that's the big announcement from the
White House we will examine the gory
details and what it means for u.s.
foreign policy and what it means for
media coverage of u.s. foreign policy
then congressman Katie hill resigns from
Congress a week or two a full week or
two after those creepy naked photos of
her exploitative relationship with her
staffer come out we will examine the
double standards of the sexual
revolution finally Kanye West comes to
Jesus all that and more I'm Michael
Knowles and this is the Michael Nolt
show
[Music]
all right we have got a lot to get to
today I also want to mention a little
bit about my very fun experience
debating Clay Aiken yesterday a
politican I know I was supposed to go in
and debate the Democrat Chris Hahn from
Fox News and somehow I ended up debating
the moderator clay Aikens so we'll try
to get to that as well first I've got to
thank my friends over at Express vpm let
me tell you something if you are
listening to this show it means that you
look at some pretty dodgy things on the
Internet all right and everybody is
trying to get your data recently over
100 million people had their personal
information stolen in a major data
breach we're talking social security
numbers we're talking contact details
credit scores and more all taken from
Capital One customers there is a good
chance that you were affected in these
kinds of attacks are getting more and
more frequent that's why I use Express
VPN you can't control how big
corporations are gonna mishandle your
data but you can protect yourself what
expressvpn does it's just an app it is
on your computer it's on your phone and
it encrypts and secures your data simple
two seconds if a breach can happen to
Capital One I bet that it can happen to
you I know you've got like tape over
your camera and your laptop but I'm just
telling you it can happen to you
expressvpn connects with just one click
it is a lightning fast it costs less
than seven bucks per month expressvpn is
rated the number one VPN provider by
TechRadar seen at the verge and
countless others right now you can use
my link expressvpn dot-com / michael mi
CH AE l do it right now you will arm
yourself with an extra three months of
expressvpn for free support the show and
protect your self and make sure that big
companies don't see all those dodgy
things you're looking at on the internet
like daily water expressvpn dot-com /
michael mi CH AE l for an extra three
months free do you remember how just a
week ago the mainstream media told us
that Isis was about to be reconstituted
Isis was coming back because Trump moved
50 soldiers in northern Syria out of
northern Syria and therefore it was
weird
of Isis all over again it's all Trump's
fault it's all the Republicans we got to
vote them out it's a no wait a second
wait I'm getting new information under
the administration Abu Bakr al-baghdadi
has been killed the leader of Isis
here's president from making the
announcement last night the United
States brought the world's number-one
terrorist leader to justice Abu Bakar al
Baghdadi is dead he was the founder and
leader of Isis the most ruthless and
violent terror organization anywhere in
the world the United States has been
searching for Baghdadi for many years
capturing or killing Baghdadi has been
the top national security priority of my
administration US Special Operations
Forces executed a dangerous and daring
nighttime raid in northwestern Syria and
accomplished their mission and grand
style this is great news great news very
well done and the message was delivered
ok we're all done right no of course
we're not done because the president is
Donald Trump so instead of just leaving
it there United States special operators
conducted a mission we it was a
dangerous mission we took out the leader
of Isis Abu Bakr al-baghdadi and that's
it that's all you're ever going to hear
about this and it's done no no no
president Trump comes out and he he just
describes what all of us want to hear
which is the gory details here's the
president we're incredible
I got to watch much of it no personnel
were lost in the operation well a large
number of Baghdadi's fighters and
companions were killed with him he died
after running into a dead-end tunnel
whimpering and crying and screaming all
the way the compound had been cleared by
this time with people either surrender
or being shot and killed 11 young
children were moved out of the house and
are uninjured the only ones remaining
were Baghdady in the tunnel and he had
dragged three of his young children with
him
they were led to certain death he
reached the end of the tunnel as our
dogs chased him down he ignited his vest
killing himself and the three children
his body was mutilated by the blast the
tunnel had caved in on it in addition
but test results gave certain immediate
and totally positive identification it
was him crying whimpering screaming
chased down by dogs I love it I love it
I like hearing this and it's not wrong
to like hearing this that Trump is
catching a lot of flak because they're
saying he's not behaving like Obama
he didn't give Abu Bakr al-baghdadi a
proper funeral you remember after we
killed Osama bin Laden they gave him a
proper funeral and we never saw any
photos and we never saw any confirmation
of this Trump is going out there he's
saying we went out there we picked up
the guts and the gore and all the
remains in the cave and we made sure it
was him and we chased him down like an
animal
good we should hear that there was a
time in this country when we weren't
afraid to show the inhumanity of our
enemy and it's important to show the
inhumanity of our enemy it's important
to have some moral clarity Abu Bakr
al-baghdadi was one of the worst people
in the world
he raped killed pillaged and burned he
was a true monster and an animal and
it's proper to describe him as such we
used to do this
there is nothing especially moral about
restraining yourself when talking about
a vicious enemy like this there's
nothing particularly moral about not
celebrating this victory of killing the
worst
terrorist leader in the world this is
this is this is what the president does
in many ways he's being criticized for
being unpresidential here this is the
role of the president we've talked a lot
about how the founders are so brilliant
they set up our separation of powers our
three branches of government to
correspond to the three parts of the
human soul there is the logos the pathos
and the ethos so there's the logical
part there's just the rigorous logical
part that's the Supreme Court that's the
judiciary branch those are the guys who
are just looking at the facts does it
always work out that way absolutely not
but that's how it's supposed to work out
then you have the emotional branch the
branch that corresponds to appetites the
Wills of the people that would be the
Congress that's why they're elected
every two years in Congress and in the
Senate they're elected every six years
they are much more responsive and
reactive to what the people themselves
want and then you have the ethos the
spirited part the part that represents
the spirit of the nation that would be
the president that's the executive
branch which does not exist simply to
deliberate and to contemplate and to
only use faculties of reason it is using
the spirit this is why the President of
the United States is not just some
functionary at the post office that's
why not all government employees are
exactly the same he is actually
representing something about our spirit
as a country I remember after 9/11 I
think it was on 9/11 President Bush gave
his speech and he said the images that
we're seeing on television of planes
flying into buildings fills us with deep
sadness and a quiet unyielding anger
it's my favorite line of the speech
because it wasn't just some polished
political speech written by some Harvard
Graduate it represented what all
Americans were feeling which is in part
what we are asking the president to do
to represent our spirit in one person in
one branch same thing actually another
George Bush example when he went down to
the pile on 9/11 he had that bullhorn
and someone said he said we can't hear
you
because he they couldn't hear him giving
a speech and he said well I can hear you
and the rest of the world hears you and
the people who knocked these buildings
down are going to hear from
all of us soon that's not a workshop
speech that's not the kind of thing you
put in front of focus groups that's just
really expressing a genuine aspect of
the spirit that's what Trump was doing
with Abu Bakr al-baghdadi I wish that
President Obama had reacted that way to
the death of Osama bin Laden
what Osama bin Laden did was traumatic
for the nation it was incredibly
traumatic certainly the greatest
national trauma of my lifetime and
probably the greatest national trauma
since the Civil War that demands a a
response that's that's not simply
clinical that's not just stating the
facts
this really matters to people you know
after Trump announced that the Isis
leader Abu Bakr al Baghdadi had been
killed in this US raid the mother of
Kayla Muller or I don't know how to
pronounce a name Muller or Mueller the
this was the American aid worker who was
kidnapped by Isis in 2013 repeatedly
sexually abused by Abu Bakr al-baghdadi
himself the mother said her daughter
might still be alive if President Obama
had been as decisive as president Trump
does Trump get credit for killing Abu
Bakr al Baghdadi yes it's not like he
was pulling the trigger I mean it was
the special operators who went into this
really risky mission but he gets credit
in the way that Obama gets credit for
killing killing Osama bin Laden because
he made the decision he's the decider
ultimately that decision goes up to the
presidential level and Obama made it so
he gets some credit for killing killing
Osama bin Laden and Trump made that
decision so he gets some credit for
killing Abu Bakr al-baghdadi the the
mother of this abducted aide aide worker
said I still say Kayla should be here
and if Obama had been as decisive as
president Trump maybe she would have
been for me what matters most I'm hoping
now we will finally get the answers we
have been asking for all along I think
this administration truly might help us
I don't think they are as closed about
what happened this is pretty harsh
language against President Obama she's
saying he just wasn't decisive now he
was decisive when it came to Osama bin
Laden but it is strange that Isis began
on Obama
watch and it began largely because we we
so quickly withdrew from Iraq that the
Islamic state was able to to come up
he didn't get it Obama didn't get it you
know they they harangue Bush because
Bush didn't get bin Laden and then Obama
did well Obama didn't get Isis didn't
get Abu Bakr al-baghdadi and Trump did
and I'm sure you're gonna see very
different reactions to those two stories
based on where people fall on the
political aisle now Trump is also
getting criticism about this it's
unbelievable you kill the worst
terrorist in the world and somehow you
get criticized for it
Trump is also getting criticism because
he did not inform congressional
Democrats that the raid was about to
happen now
President Trump I think has a pretty
good reason for this he said he didn't
want it to leak here's here's his
explanation we spoke to the Russians we
told them we're coming in and they said
thank you for telling us they were very
good no they did not know why we did
tell them we think you're gonna be very
happy because you know again they hate
Isis as much as we do you know what Isis
has done to Russia so no we did not tell
they did not know the mission but they
knew we were going over an area that
they had they had a lot of firepower
we've notified some others are being
notified now as I speak we were going to
notify them last night but we decided
not to do that because Washington leaks
like I've never seen before there's
nothing there's no country in the world
that leaks what like we do and
Washington is a leaking machine and I
told my people we will not notify them
until the our great people are out not
just in but out I don't want to have
them greeted with firepower like you
wouldn't believe
fair enough he says look Washington
leaks all the time you got leaks
especially coming out of Adam Schiff
like crazy leaks even coming out of our
Intel
community so I'm not gonna let you guys
know totally fair and the left is sort
of proving his point here in their
reaction to the killing of al-baghdadi I
mean they're you now have on MSNBC you
somehow have MSNBC panelists discussing
how killing the worst terrorist in the
world actually capital a/c ksh actually
killing the worst terrorist in the world
is a bad thing because I don't know
MSNBC can explain it I wonder here if
this type of killing only reinforces the
ideology of Baghdadi's followers and in
fact strengthens it well it doesn't make
it any easier for those of us who want
to destroy the organization completely
it's really actually bad it's really you
know killing the leader of this
organization now makes it really hard to
destroy the organization and you know
frankly look if we kill them you know
they kind of they win you know if you
really think about it you know but if
you really think about it this is a
completely ridiculous argument and
they're making it because this is a this
is an unobjectionable win for the White
House this is an absolute good for the
country they're there they've really
done something right here we have
defeated Isis and I think the real
reason that the left is so upset about
it
is is really the timing - it's so cuts
against the narrative that we were
hearing just last week the narrative was
Isis is about to reform I learned it
from some Republicans who didn't want
Trump to pull those troops out of
northern Syria and not only is Isis not
currently reforming Isis has now been
struck the most decisive blow in the
history of Isis this is a cause for some
skepticism now when we approached the
mainstream media because their
predictions just keep being so wrong the
greatest example of this is actually not
MSNBC I don't even want to really pick
on MSNBC the greatest example of this is
the Washington Post
The Washington Post where democracy dies
and darkness ran an obituary for the
leader of Isis that read I am NOT I am
not making it up it said that Abu Bakr
al Baghdadi an austere religious scholar
and leader of the Islamic state dies an
austere religious scholar Adolf Hitler
passionate community planner and dynamic
public speaker dies at 56 that was one
version that went around on on Twitter
another one Mao Zedong who saved twenty
to forty five million of his own people
from having to suffer through the
struggle of existence dies at 82 I put
one out said Attila the Hun renowned
world traveler and government
administrator dies at 46 II when I saw
this Washington Post headline I did not
believe it and I it is not possible for
me to have less respect for the
Washington Post than I currently do and
yet even I said this has to be a Babylon
be parody of of the Washington Post no
it was it was real they then changed the
headlight changed the headline a few
times it was extremist leader but a lot
of it focused on Abu Bakr al Baghdadi z'
of scholarly training on his expertise
in Islam and it's such an irony because
all we heard during the rise of Isis is
that the Islamic state has nothing to do
with Islam here's Barack Obama saying as
much now let's make two things clearly
ISIL is not Islamic no religion condones
let's be clear let's be perfectly clear
Abu Bakr al-baghdadi who has a PhD in
Islamic theology from Baghdad University
that he doesn't know that nearly as much
about Islam as me some guy in America
who's not a Muslim let me be perfectly
clear he also calls them ISIL instead of
Isis which everybody called him he Bhama
would call them ISIL because it if he
called him Isis it would acknowledge
that oh bomb
had completely bungled Iraq and Syria
the Islamic state of Iran if Iraq and
Syria so he called him ISIL which was
the Islamic state in the Levant or the
Islamic State of Iraq and the Levant
which was a little muddier and so Obama
didn't have to take total credit for it
but he completely bungled the thing up
and it exposes this line the left wants
to have it both ways the left wants to
revere this austere religious scholar
that one is like gosh this guy really
knew a lot about Islam and then say but
also he doesn't know anything about
Islam it depends what argument they're
trying to make about the religion of
peace we'll get to that in one second
but first speaking of safety I got to
thank our friends over at ring rings
mission is to make neighborhoods safer
now you probably already know about
their smart video doorbells because I
tell you about them those protect
millions of people everywhere ring helps
you stay connected to your home anywhere
in the world so if there is a package
delivery or if there is a guy trying to
break into your home or if your
mother-in-law is going to stop by you
can see here and speak to them from
anywhere you could be in your bedroom
you could be in the office you could be
on a beach somewhere so if it's the
Amazon guy you know you can say hey drop
the package here if it's a robber you
can say hey you get it get out of my
house you robber and if it's your
mother-in-law you can stay perfectly
quiet and hope that the lights are off
and not make a sound and then maybe
she'll go away and and you'll be able to
go on with your day that is all thanks
to the HD video and two-way audio
features on ring devices I really like
ring I give ring out to my friends as a
housewarming gift because it's
incredible technology it makes you feel
like you're living in the future and in
the Jetsons it makes you feel so much
safer against uploaded the video gets
uploaded to the cloud so if the robber
steals your ring you'll still be fine
and then this is the most important part
when I'm considering gifts for my
friends it's not that expensive it's a
pretty good deal it's like a really
really good deal so those are the most
important aspects and my friends always
appreciate it you know I have my senior
producer was able to catch some wackos
before they broke into his house and my
other friends caught a possum they
thought it was a burglar and it was a
possum now they like the possum as a
listener you have a special offer on a
ring starter kit available right now
with a video doorbell and
motion-activated floodlight camera
starter kit has everything you need to
start building a ring of security around
your home go to ring.com slash knowles
that is ring.com slash Knowles
I love the Washington Post headline
because it admits that the left has been
lying for years when they say that Isis
has nothing to do with Islam if Isis has
nothing to do with Islam then I guess
the leader of Isis Abu Bakr al Baghdadi
is not much of a religious scholar if he
is a religious scholar he probably knows
something about Islam and the answer is
of course he knows something about Islam
he knows a lot more about it than Barack
Obama does or any of the American left
who have never cracked open the the
binding on the Quran isn't even ever
read a page of it have never studied
anything about the religion and simply
say that it is the religion of peace now
is that to say that that Isis represents
all of Islam everywhere all around the
world no of course not but it does admit
that there is a complex question here
and it's not a complete coincidence that
radical Islamic terrorism has some
coincidence with Islam and Abu Bakr
al-baghdadi he was a really important
figure in this way as well I mean that
the fact that he was a religious scholar
does matter because he did command some
serious credibility on Islamic theology
he also was one of the most notorious
terrorists in the world he got chased
down by dogs screaming and whimpering
and now he's dead that is a very good
thing the bad news for the left ear bad
news for Democrats especially on the
hill this is not going to help them in
their impeachment argument killing
really really really bad guys tends to
boost your president's popularity I I
nearly liked Barack Obama for six or
seven hours after he made the decision
to go kill Osama bin Laden this is
really gonna hurt their impeachment
calls it's really gonna knock their
credibility and that's not the only way
that Democrats are facing on the hill
right now Democrats on the hill also
have to deal with the resignation of
representative Katie Hill a total weirdo
pervert who was engaged in a throuple
with her huh pole as a couple for three
people a throuple with her husband and a
22 year old staffer so we're not we're
not even just talking about perfectly
fun free loved consensual do whatever
you want to do man we're talking about
what the left in any other situation
would call sexual harassment we're
talking about inappropriate
relationships with young female staffers
we're talking about the me2 movement
except it's never the me2 movement when
it comes to Democrats so there were some
reactions to this I mean there were so
many photos that came out Katie Hill
could no longer sustain this there was
one photo of her sitting completely
naked behind her completely clothed
female staffer brushing the staffers
hair these photos were so far beyond
sexy like they were so far beyond
anything that any normal person could
remotely consider titillating and they
just were fully 100% creepy there was no
nothing titillating was left in them so
she's she's brushing the hair that
wasn't even the weirdest one there was
another photo of naked Katie Hill the
Democratic congressman ripping a bong
and showing her iron cross tattoo she
had a Nazi era German tattoo on her body
well ripping a bong well doing a bunch
of drugs well sexually harassing her
staffer even for the left they couldn't
defend this anymore so they they kick
her out you know she resigns she could
no longer sustain it even at that point
the left wasn't going down without a
fight so BuzzFeed runs the greatest
headline of all this I think officially
wins the award for dumbest article on
the Internet today the headline
representative Katie Hill will resign
after details of her sex life were
published oh my gosh Jeffrey Epstein was
driven to suicide after shameless
tabloids
leaked details of his personal life
that's not the story guys the story is
she enters
who seems like kind of a creepy guy -
were exploiting this young staffer in
weird threesomes that they would go on
and taking photos of it and taking
photos of using illicit drugs and taking
photos of the congressman's naked body
with Nazi tattoos oh and also the
congressman Katie Hill is leaving her
husband and her 22 year old staffer
because she's also been sleeping with
her male finance director so awful I
can't believe those tabloids a leaked
details of her sex left so she's the
real victim here if you ask me you know
if you really think about it but
actually but actually this is such rank
hypocrisy and I just the article goes on
I have I have to keep reading hill said
her supporters should quote no longer be
subjected to the pain inflicted by my
abusive husband and the brutality of
political operatives so funny the
husband has made a few pet Facebook
posts here and because initially Katie
hill tried to spin this as she's
discovering her sexuality and she's
becoming a lesbian and it's therefore a
good thing that she's leaving her
husband and her husband posted and said
you're leaving me for a man you're not a
lesbian we we've been engaged in this
weird threesome for a few years but
you're not you're not leaving me for a
woman I don't know why that would be
good if you leave your husband for a
woman but it's definitely not good if
you're leaving your husband for another
guy who's also an employee of yours
nothing about this is defensible Katie
Hill but she said my abusive husband and
of course the brutality of political
operatives how dare those political
operatives make Katie hill take naked
photos with her staffers ripping bonds
and having Nazi tattoos so awful of them
to do that the piece goes on
representative Katie Hill is resigning
from Congress amid an allegation that
she had an inappropriate relationship
with a member of her staff I guess
allegation is a new word for many
photographs she's resigning from many
amid many photographs coming out showing
her inappropriate relationship they go
on the conservative website red state
published text messages and photos
indicating that Hill had been in a
consensual sexual relationship with a
female staffer on her campaign and that
she was also involved with a male
staffer in her congressional office
it's just that awful conservative
website that showed that totally
consensual relationships also if a male
boss ever pays a compliment to any
female employee he's done he's got to be
fired and thrown out and he's been
practically a rapist but if a female
congressman has a completely
exploitative relationship with her 22
year-old female staffer where the
staffer actually describes herself as
having been heartbroken and ripped apart
by this that is wonderful and consensual
and Wow great job that's that's the
sexual revolution the piece goes on Hill
who is openly bisexual admitted and
apologized for having a relationship
with a female staffer but denied any
improper relationship with the male
staffer Hill says those clay that claims
came from her ex-husband whom she is
divorcing okay okay all of this just
shows you how little you really can
trust the media and the left I know it's
like we almost don't even need to say it
anymore
but I don't think I've seen two clearer
issues in the news in recent days and
somehow the left has managed to
completely flip them Trump kills the
most wanted notorious terrorist in the
world the heirto Asama bin Laden a
cartoonishly evil terrorist and under
Trump's watch the United States kills
him and the left somehow spins that as a
bad thing a democratic congresswoman has
a cartoonishly ridiculous affair with
one of her staffers and I mean I
couldn't if I took that script into a
Hollywood studio and I said hey I want
to do a movie about a bisexual
congressman having a throuple with her
husband and a female staffer and also
she combs her hair and well naked and
the staffers clothes and also she's
ripping bong hits on camera you see all
of this oh and also she has Nazi tattoos
if I handed that into the Hollywood
studio they would say that's too
on-the-nose Michael you've got that's
ridiculous a clear case and yet somehow
the mainstream media portrays the
congressman as a victim
what this means is the next time the
media give you some outrage the next
time they say Trump did the worst thing
in the world the next time they say some
Republican Congressmen do the work just
take a deep breath calm down and
remember that these guys are lying to
you and I think increasingly people are
seeing the light one guy in particular
is seeing the light he is probably the
avatar of the pop culture maybe the
biggest guy in the pop culture other
than the president himself that would be
Kanye West Kanye West has come to Jesus
he's released an album called Jesus is
king you know I don't care for hip-hop
you know I don't care for most popular
music made after World War one and
listen to the album we will analyse
Kanye's come to Jesus moment we'll see
where it stands we'll see what it means
for music for reconnaissance ole and for
the culture then if we have time we will
also talk a little bit about my debate
at politican not with Chris Hahn who is
the Fox News Democrat the aggressive
progressive that I was supposed to
debate but actually a debate where I
guess Chris Chris was there he was
participating but really the debate came
from Clay Aiken who was supposed to be
the moderator Clay Aiken totally
objective unbiased you can watch and
listen to that whole debate on YouTube
I'll post it to my my Twitter page as
well
that was from politican 2019 we'll post
that there because it was a real trip
but first I've got to say goodbye to
Facebook and YouTube head on over to
daily wire.com
ten bucks a month $100 for an annual
membership you get me you get the Andrew
Klavan show you get the Ben Shapiro show
get the Matt Walsh show you get to ask
questions of the mailbag coming up on
Thursday you get another Kingdom which
is the last season and it's the best
season and you get the leftist ears
tumblr get it you're gonna need it
because Isis is dead Kanye is alive
things are going really really well and
the leftist tears are flowing head on
over to daily wire.com we'll be right
back
I never thought that I would do this but
I have got to do a close reading of
Kanye West because Kanye West has this
album out Jesus is king and it's quite
good now what do I mean by that I don't
care for much modern music I don't care
for hip-hop at all I really don't care
for modern Christian music I really
don't like that
so how honor this seems like the
intersection of everything I hate the
thing I like about it is I've always
felt that Kanye West has a very good ear
the line I've used about him in the past
is that he has a such a great year for
music that he then makes worse by
rapping over it but he does as a real
incredible musical talent he does hear
things not just in the music but in the
culture as well this album just reads is
very sincere and I was also afraid that
the music was going to be heretical or
Sobe or saccharine and sentimental like
so much Christian music and it's not you
know the best the best worst version of
this is a song called on eagle's wings
that they play in blue hair Vatican two
Catholic churches where there are three
people in the parish and the songs
weren't even cool in the 70s but they
all just really get into it and the song
says I will raise you up on eagle's
wings which is also not true I will
never raise anybody up because I am a
person on I am NOT God so it's it has
the is not only a terrible song to
listen to but it has the added injury of
being heretical so I was afraid we were
gonna get some of this stuff from Kanye
West or that we were just gonna get a
bunch of other kind of nonsense with
more of a hip-hop vibe it's not what we
got three songs in particular I really
liked God is closed on Sunday and water
I think you should listen to those songs
God is here are the lyrics oh you even
here just it just listen to just a
little bit to get the sense of the music
[Music]
Wow
so the song reads God is my protection
God is my all and all God is my light in
darkness
Oh God is he is my all and all God is my
joy in the time of sorrow God is my all
and all God is my today in my tomorrow
God God my God is my all and all God is
the joy and strength of my life God is
remove all pain and misery and strife
God is he promised to keep me never to
leave you he'll never ever come short of
his word I've got to fast and pray stay
in that narrow way keep my life clean
every day I want to go with him when he
comes back I've come too far and I'll
never turn back God is God is God is God
is God is my all in all it's a beautiful
song the thing that I first noticed
about the album is the songs are short
they should be sure modern musicians
tends not to have that much to say and
if you say things quickly there can be
something profound what is God you know
when when Moses asks when Moses asks God
who do I say you are God doesn't say I'm
God I'm this guy I'm that guy because
God is the essence of being God he is so
God says I am that I am I he God is so
being that he simply is the same thing
Christ is asked about his divinity and
he says before Abraham was I am Christ
is always in the present because he is
the essence of being and that is what
the song means that's the title of the
song God is profound
and simple and something that probably
has not occurred to many aficionados of
modern music God is my all and all every
line in here is true there's no no
heresy as far as I can tell my day is my
today and my tomorrow he's eternal not
not even not bound by our linear
conceptions of time he's the Alpha and
the Omega the beginning in the end he is
all of that he's he is outside
of time and space and he inserts himself
into time and space in the incarnation
my all in all this constant just going
back to God you don't want it to be like
one of these Jesus is my girlfriend
songs where you mentioned Jesus a couple
times but you could replace the word
Jesus with baby and it would just be a
regular modern song that would be
missing the point
God he keeps coming back the song is
called God is you just keep going back
to the name of God for a beautiful song
the next one is the funniest song in the
album it's called closed on Sunday and
it is a song about chick-fil-a have a
listen when you get daughters always
keep them safe watch out the fibers
don't let them and doctrine a closed on
Sunday
you might chick-fil-a love it love it
great stuff Kanye the other thing I was
worried about this album is that Kanye
was just gonna take himself too
seriously Chesterton said the angels can
fly because they can take themselves
lightly Kanye can take himself lightly
here as well
it's it's one of the catchy or songs on
the album and it's just very funny
closed on Sunday your might chick-fil-a
closed on Sunday you're my chick-fil-a
hold the selfies put the gram away put
the Instagram away get your family y'all
hold hands and pray when you got
daughters always keep them safe watch
out for vipers don't let them in
doctrine aid closed on Sunday you're my
chick-fil-a so this is a song about the
Sabbath and it's a song about
chick-fil-a and it's because chick-fil-a
is representative of the modern culture
and it's even an example of being in the
consumer culture in modern America but
still keeping holy the Sabbath day but
still keeping holy sacred things but not
totally losing yourself in these this
den of vipers not totally losing
yourself in this completely illusory
culture of Instagram and this totally
self-centered idea of selfies not losing
yourself and trying to make more money
on Sunday this this idea that you will
take a moment and reflect and
contemplate you're my chick-fil-a closed
on Sunday you're much of a you're my
number one with the lemonade
they've lemonade at chick-fil-a raise
our sons trained them in the faith
through temptations make sure they're
wide awake follow Jesus listen and obey
no more living for the culture we
nobody's slave or nobody's slave even in
the consumer culture we're not gonna be
wage slaves we're not going to because
if you work I mean this is one of one of
the many explanations of the Sabbath is
no matter how much money you make no
matter how successful you are if you are
constantly working if you are working
100 percent of the time you're a slave
doesn't it you could own the biggest
corporation in the world
you're still a slave to your appetites
for money for to your appetite for power
to all to your appetites literally for
the chicken sandwich the chicken
sandwich is representing those appetites
in Kanye West is saying
we're gonna closed on Sunday to raise
our kids to have our family to
contemplate God most importantly to
follow Jesus we're not living for the
culture we're not living for Mammon and
for the here and now we are living for a
kingdom that is not of this world he
goes on stand up for my home even if I
take this walk alone I bow down to the
king upon my the throne my life is his
I'm no longer my own I pray to God that
he'll strengthen my hand
they will think twice stepping on my
land I draw the line it's written in the
sand try me and you will see that I
ain't plan now back up off my family
move your hands I got my weapons in the
spirits land it what an amazing turn you
know so much of popular hip-hop music
speaks about violence sometimes it
advocates violence and Kanye is nodding
to that here and he's speaking not about
physical warfare he's speaking about
spiritual warfare we are fighting
against principalities and powers we are
fighting against spiritual darkness not
just random people on the street this is
just a position of the modern the
material the things that satisfy our
appetites in this world and the
spiritual in the metaphysical world this
this juxtaposition in the very funny
catch of chick-fil-a is is really quite
smart he says Jezebel don't even stand a
chance Jezebel don't even stand a chance
really really good song and it's funny
and if you can tell when people have
lost the narrative no matter how
well-intentioned they are when they
completely lose their sense of humor
Kanye hasn't in many ways he's gained
more of a sense of humor in this shows
you maybe he's on the right path and
then the last song people aren't talking
about it as much but I think it's really
really good is a song called water give
a listen
[Music]
I promise
[Music]
it's water that's the name of the song
listen to the lyrics clean us like the
rain and spring take the chlorine out of
our conversation let your light reflect
on me I promise I'm not hiding anything
it's water we're water purest water like
a newborn daughter the imagery of the
water is the imagery of baptism of
rebirth it's the imagery of laundering
your soul in the confessional it's the
laundry or it's the the imagery rather
of taking something which is dirty in
making it clean and not artificially
clean but really clean you know even
this cleanness like the rain in spring
take the chlorine out of our
conversation take the artificial
sanitizing aspect out of our
conversation present ourselves as really
as dirty and damaged as we are by
original sin and clean us clean us let
your light reflect on me I promise I'm
not hiding anything I'm not hiding it
there's no chlorine in our conversation
I'm not holding anything back here's
what I am please clean me pure as water
in the baptism pure as water like a
newborn daughter that the use of
daughter here is interesting his
daughter in the song just because it
rhymes with water
perhaps I mean I'm sure that helps I've
talked to many songwriter friends of
mine I'll say what about that lyric and
I'll say oh it sounded good this so I'm
sure that has some part of it but it
actually doesn't really matter what's
going on in the artists mind what
matters is the work of art itself and to
mention puris water like a newborn
daughter has something beautiful because
it's it's avoiding some of the worse
aspects of modern versions of
Christianity as they they really don't
capture the whole of the faith and in
particular what they lose is a feminine
side of the faith the notion that we are
the Bride of Christ the church is
literally the bride to the bridegroom
who is Christ the idea that the Marian
aspect of things the idea that Mary
plays a an incredibly significant role
the history of salvation roll that we
will never know until we get to heaven
the that Mary is born with that original
sin in the Immaculate Conception that's
the traditional understanding of Mary
like a newborn daughter it captures an
aspect in a way that is lovely it's
really a lovely song and has lovely
music goes on the storm may come but
we'll get through it because of your
love either way we crash like water your
loves water pure as water
Jesus flow through us this is where
Konya comes in and just this is the
verse Jesus flow through us Jesus heal
the bruises Jesus clean the music Jesus
please use us Jesus please help Jesus
please heal Jesus please forgive this is
a total acceptance of grace not the
Pelagian heresy if I'm going to work for
and it's about me and it's only about my
struggles you play a role in your city
you have a role to play in your
salvation because you have free will and
you can turn away from God but if you
turn toward God and allow that grace to
come it is over flowing like water you
see this even in the Annunciation when
the angel Gabriel comes down to Mary
God's grace comes all the way down the
mountain and then heaven holds its
breath when it the angel says hail Mary
full of grace the Lord is with you and
the angel says you will conceive a child
she she doesn't understand how that's
possible and she says I am The Lord's
servant his will be done the heavens
hold their breath well Mary a sense to
God's will but God's will is overflowing
like water and this constant going back
Jesus Jesus Jesus just like God is God
God God it's going all back to Jesus -
to living water we are and then we
become as water because we are taken
into the body of Christ st. st. Paul
uses this city says I wish to dissolve
coupie Oh dissolve it is no longer I who
live who lives but Christ who lives in
me
pure as water really beautiful song it's
and it's one that's not getting enough
attention on the album I encourage you
to listen to a Kanye West album never
thought I would say that but somehow
hope somehow in in this political world
that we're living in and the cultural
world in this religious world our
expectations are confound
President Trump doing a lot of good
things
Isis is dead Kanye West is alive they
are subverting our expectations why when
I saw this news come out you know that
Isis is completely dead somehow we were
told it was it was gonna be the exact
opposite Isis was gonna be reconstitute
and we saw it came out I said wow that's
great news then I saw Kanye West
releases an album called Jesus's king
which all the fears I had about it that
it would be about Kanye that it would be
about that it would be saccharine that
it would be bad there would be heretical
none of those come true it's actually
profound and it's it's an album that's
not focused on the self and it's doing I
think a lot of good in the culture might
my conclusion of that is we are living
in the greatest timeline this is good
news Isis is dead Kanye is alive and
there is hope for the culture hope
springs eternal in the human breast
because hope is not just a feeling it's
not up optimism or pessimism some
shallow feeling it's a fact hope is a
fact and you're gonna have hope in very
real events very real things it's really
in reality really really really in
reality we don't have too much time to
talk about politican so I have to
encourage you to go over and watch and
listen to the debate I debated Chris on
the Fox News Democrat in Nashville
yesterday at politican and very quickly
the debate became not just me against
Chris on it became me against Chris Hahn
and Clay Aiken to liberals debating one
conservative so you know it's a fair
fight even then you should go check it
out because clay really lost it I mean
he melted down he started swearing at
the audience he he really let his left
isms show and I think it's a pretty good
example in what clay was doing about
what the left does when conservatives
don't let them shut us up so go check it
out in the meantime I'm Michael noses
the Michael Nolt show see you tomorrow
I always keep them safe watch out for
fibers
don't let them indoctrinate closed on
Sunday
you might chick-fil-a
[Music]
the Michael Noel's show is produced by
Rebecca dabka wits and directed by Mike
joiner executive producer Jeremy bore
senior producer Jonathan hey our
supervising producer is Mathis clever
and our technical producer is Austin
Stephens assistant director pavel y
douse key edited by danny D'Amico audio
is mixed by mike core amina hair and
makeup is by joshua alvera and our
production assistant is nick Chien the
Michael Noel's show is a daily wire
production copyright daily wire 20 19 on
the Matt Walsh show we're not just
discussing politics we're talking
culture faith family all of the things
that are really important to you so come
join the conversation
you